the whole idea for the movie came from
Andrew Nichols brain which can be an
awesome place yeah and basically when we
turn 25 the the aging gene stops we
figured out how to look 25 forever but
the risk of that you know there's that's
the good part the bad part is what
happens at that point is your body clock
starts sitting on your left forearm and
you have a year of time that you save up
until the time you're 25 it starts and
so so basically you start running out of
time now you can make time you can steal
time you can borrow time it's all kind
of transmitted through your pulse and so
I play will a sort of an everyday man
from the slums who wakes up with 23
hours on his clock every day so he has
less than a day to live and so he's he's
almost like a rat in a maze you know
constantly running the wheel so to speak
has to work he works at a factory for
time and
that's kind of that's where the movie
starts run out of time you have heart
attack you die which is which is really
kind of an amazing concept because you
just have these dead bodies on the
street and we could have we could have
gotten really morbid with it but it's
pretty pretty cut-and-dry like you run
out of time that's it if the doctors if
scientist ayan sweevo figure out how to
live forever then that I'm sure the
government is going to find a way to
steer away from overpopulation and
that's you know that was sort of the
paradox that Andrew you know is the
emphasis for it for it for that for this
movie and it's it's and on top of that
you have these two characters you have
minor comes from a very poor part of
town and Amanda's character Sylvia who
comes from a very rich part of town and
we end up together on the run through
these crazy you know extenuating
circumstances and it's a thrill ride the
whole movie I'm basically live I'm
basically trying I wake up at 23 hours
on my clock every day I come across a
guy who looks the same age as me but
he's a hundred and five years old and I
play a 28 year old
and basically basically what happens is
I become accused wrongly accused of a
murder and go on the run and I make my
way to the rich part of town through a
crazy series of events I end up
kidnapping
Amanda's character Sylvia and holding
her hostage and we go on the run all
your time time is money he was all time
at some point like right in the
beginning when he goes into the rich
part of the world and and she then he
gets caught there's also money kidnaps
me and then we kind of well then there's
that I don't want to didn't mind it was
terrible yeah I think it's it's one of
those concepts that really does work
sometimes you read something and it's
just so existential II just can't wrap
your mind around and this you can this
makes actual sense when you're done with
the script you're like I got this really
good place
seems possible even though it's not it
actually makes you feel like anything's
possible because he's written
I mean he's there's so many different
ideas and they all make sense they all
work there it's a big puzzle that just
goes together in Andrews brain and he's
expressing that on paper and the story
really in-depth characters he has Andrew
Gattaca you know he wrote The Truman
Show directing Gattaca Lord of war he
has the uncanny ability to take a
thrilling concept and also show you you
know a little you know there's a little
irony so what he does with his films
because he's he's the king of the of the
socia of the social commentary thriller
you know to be able to thrill you with
an intimate story like my story would go
on the run and it's been it's you know
it's an action movie the whole time and
you're and you're you're constantly
you're trying to keep up but at the same
time you I feel like you walk out of
this movie going huh you know is that
kind of a reflection if time really is
money in this world that we've created
that Andrews created is is is that sort
of like a roundabout reflection in a way
of perhaps our economy you know you take
this world that we live in
immediately gets split up you know with
with the way with the with the situation
we're in it immediately gets split up
into two classes very rich and very poor
and so there's no middle class so but
I'll that's what I love about Andrews
movie I mean that's what got me and
invested as well as it's so many things
I mean my favorite action movies were
always about ordinary guys in die hard
and the fugitive and there are elements
of there are themes in those movie that
movies that I really felt like I tried
to carry with me on on this film and
they're totally original characters it's
exciting to be at comic-con talking
about original characters I actually I
actually tore my calf on set I was very
painful
and so that sucked tossed around in a
car a little bit ya know this movie
hurts to me there's a lot of injuries
it's a lot like I'd go home and you know
you're working here you're in it you're
constantly blocking out all you know
physical pain yeah I get home and I know
these scratches and bruises and bloody
knuckles and how did I get that I wasn't
enough fight
you know apparently Andrew Nichols
movies will physically harm you we saw
it recently and it looks chic in
shooting he really brings out all the
elements of like Andrew Andrews world
like physically just the aesthetics is
just amazing so in tune with it's
actually really I haven't seen a film
within this genre that I've felt felt
like has been this intimate and
performance driven because I mean
honestly we want people to love our
characters too we want them to follow
our characters and that's that's the
biggest part of getting the audience and
any any charm and I feel like that's
what we were able to do in sort of
working with Andrew on the characters
was let's make them you put everything I
just described as such a fantastical
idea but it doesn't work unless you take
unless you unless the actors and you
know Killian and Olivia Wilde and
everyone who Vincent Kartheiser everyone
who's in the movie they brought such a
real grounded approach to their
characters and so you feel like you're
really there with them and and and it's
actually way more intimate
I even thought it was going to be